[Music]
hello and welcome to GameSpot daily
where we cover six news stories in 30
minutes or less and this is our first
episode ever
hello everyone welcome thank you for
being here yeah i'm callie and you are
hi my name is michael hyoma I work here
at GameSpot believe it or not and so
does Callie
we are both we were both on the
editorial staff but today and for the
rest of our lives
we're here to bring y'all some news
stories you know it's gonna be it's
gonna be chill we're just gonna wanna
take it easy yeah we have a conversation
about the hottest stuff going on cuz uh
that's what we're here to do until we
die yes okay so let's just start
hopefully forever but uh all right story
number one ready yes pop jeez desert map
is coming to Xbox one next month finally
I don't took them long enough
took them away long enough so pub G Corp
announced that Miramar the desert map is
coming to Xbox one in May and more
information will be available soon yeah
the the announcement was made during an
Xbox Live session with Brendon green and
your boy Major Nelson at a with deadmau5
at PAX East so you can love it we can
look at it some some live footage from
the PAX East reveal that the new map is
coming to the Xbox version and he wore a
pub key themed helmet with paint with
pants uh I just want to say that I don't
know what year it is anymore
no because deadmau5 is he not relevant
anymore is it I think it's the kids
listen to deadmau5 no way damn deadmau5
is like stopping a thing in like 2012
probably is a bold a statement so I
guess I'd wasn't really and I just think
it's funny because fortnight had Drake
right oh yeah four nights for the
culture you know Sam deadmau5 um so I
don't know about that but I don't know
the news of the day is that yeah that
new map Miramar which PC players have
been playing for a quite a long time
that came in December when pub she went
1.0 release for the PC so us in the
office have been playing
app a lot and it's calm our feelings for
it have evolved over time I was gonna
say if you're on Xbox you too can
discover the hatred for miramar well the
love for it at first because it's like
oh snap we got a new map finally yeah
and then a couple matches later you be
like damn this map is not that great but
I personally had like aspects of the new
map or the second map yeah no there's
there's parts of it I like but I got
real tired of Miramar and you know for a
while people were like deleting the file
so they wouldn't even get it in the
queue mm-hmm
so Xbox welcome to the party yeah and
yeah for those who have been playing pub
G almost exclusively on Xbox Miramar is
a desert theme map that has a lot of
open space I would say yes one of the
one of the problems or gripes that
people have had with the new map is that
there are long stretches between the
city centers where you have almost no
cover at all so you're a sitting duck
for the entire time unless even if
you're in a vehicle because there's many
times in this in the second map where
I'm in a vehicle with like Jake and Nick
and stuff we were just like rolling
through like trying to cross the big-ass
desert and we just got rolled up on yeah
like easy I know in the first map
there's a lot of ways you can weave in
and out of like the trees or the
cornfields or whatever there's always
like a shack on the side to kind of like
stake out in but in the second map
you're kind of like once you get shot at
in the open fields you're done son like
I like that we're talking up the desert
map but they gotta get into the island I
actually have a video pulled up of the
desert oh do you but sorry I do what I
cut back to us real quick but oh yeah
boom it's an R it's in one of our
previous videos that showed a case tit
for the PC version we have an ad of
course yeah Decker there you go yes one
of the this is the reveal video that
Jake did once we got this back in
December there's so many stretches where
you can just get sniped on Miramar and
it gets really frustrating yeah if
there's a lot of cool stuff in it though
I like the some of the interiors - those
buildings look pretty neat I know
there's like a luchador wrestling arena
somewhere in there
yeah there's there's a casino there's a
casino yeah I haven't been to the casino
is dope besides what have I not been to
the casino these these maps are huge
there's constantly things I'm seeing
that I haven't seen before on the island
I like recently found a lighthouse and I
was like wait there's lighthouses
there's a lighthouse
a review pub D&I there's still things
I'm learning about it right and then in
other pub G news obviously the smaller
the new map codename savage right was on
the test server and we did a video of it
if you're interested in hearing more
about that but you can watch it after
our show cuz you love our shows because
we got a lot more going on again like I
said we're gonna hit six stories so that
was our first one kicking off with our
nail girl story it was a lucky all right
and then also going back in time from
deadmau5 to Resident Evil 7 which isn't
that far back which isn't as far back
but it has sold over five million copies
yes 5.1 million to be somewhat exact and
this is across all platforms ps4 Xbox
one and PC
mm-hmm and that was Capcom that
announced that recently according to
steams by about 550 thousand of those
are PC players that's a pretty small
portion yeah actually it's like 10% of
the overall sales came from PC yeah I
mean I guess you have the PSB our
support so it makes more sense to that
game on PlayStation yeah yeah this news
came from a press release about Resident
Evil 7 specifically winning best VR
audio in a 2018 game audio Network Guild
Awards didn't know that was the thing
yeah but no game audio Network Guild I'm
gonna let that sink that's dope yeah
yeah and then in related news Capcom
released an Xbox one X update for
doesn't evil 7 that adds 4k and HDR
support but you still don't got that
sweet sweet VR oh yeah that's right oh
man I would want this to be on on 5 or
occu my god
you'd get a heart attack I know John
Luke played all of Resident Evil 7 in VR
and really liked it mhm
he did a really good feature about that
did it's still like I'm still so
impressed by it it was like that's oh my
god it was over a year ago yeah snap
yeah Resident Evil 7 came out in January
2017 yes yes and too much years of
people surprised that it was a it really
tapped into what R is and evils but what
the series was all about while staying
in first person like even playing this
myself it's like yeah this is I
definitely feel it yeah it totally
captured for me the the spirit of made
Resident Evil good but it it wasn't just
like reach reading this year like
obviously it's first-person it's
different from the previous games but it
felt more like older Resident Evil yes
to play most definitely but yeah this
game has been out for over a year it
gotten fourth place in game spots 2017
best games of the year which is indeed
it is if there are a lot of a lot of
fans here in this office of resin Evil 7
for a good reason obviously if you know
Mike McCarty and Mary Kish they do that
recipe Resident Evil yeah say they got
through seven yeah they've been playing
all the Resident Evil games and it's
very fun because Mary will come into the
office and we can just hear her
screaming or the office like there's a
murder happening it's great these rooms
are soundproof but apparently uh not
soundproof enough for Mary yeah cool
yeah so that's evil if you're not part
of the 5.1 million who have purchased
the Resident Evil 7 we certainly can
because it's out there that's good yeah
Battle Royale news is always a guarantee
here I promise you so if you're into it
you can stick around for more battle
rounds but today instead of fortnight in
pub G we're also talking about law
breakers well the law breakers dev has
revealed its new battle royale game so
you don't know that's boss ki and that's
cliffy B's game company yes um you know
cliffy B I who doesn't know cliffie
cliffie B's uh he has a history and the
games industry oh yeah so the game's
called radical Heights and it hits steam
early access on April 10th which is oh
my god this tomorrow RL tomorrow
according to Cliff Bleszinski radical
Heights and I really want to emphasize
the
capitalization in this is a free extreme
early access no no it's X - dream dream
dream literally like what year is it
the theme of this episode it's extreme
early access battle royale shooter
extreme early access as in like it's
early early so yes the next the next
wave of or the next person or company
doing a battle royale game is cliffy B
and boskie now if you're not familiar
with Cliff Bleszinski he is he was a
creator or one of the creators of the
original unreal back in 1999 mm-hmm I
believe or he was involved development
of that so and he's been a big part of
Epic Games he's kind of the creative
mind behind Gears of War yep so cliffy B
is no I mean if you're not familiar with
Cliff Bleszinski he's like no he's not
any developer he's done some big things
he does some stuff and then obviously
most recently boskie did law breakers
which if you're familiar with the lore
of law breakers that game not a lot of
people played that games let's just yes
to put to put it lightly yeah
but but more about radical height
radical radical radical heights tasks
you with your typical last person
standing battle royale gameplay but it
also features two things that I didn't
think would be in the same sentence BMX
bikes and ATMs not ATVs I know
ATMs I was like whoa I thought it was a
typo yeah when we were looking at this I
was like not ATVs no literally like
automated teller machines so it seems
you can farm in-game cash deposit it
into the ATM and then withdraw it late
like in a future round mm-hmm so it's
got a little bit more meta yeah
traditional style I suppose yeah and
obviously like if you're watching the
show not just listening we're seeing the
trailer now plans to have radical
Heights and early access for about a
year yeah and I guess that means which
they would that's that's some extreme
really access yeah that's actually not a
lot of time to be honest I mean Battle
Royale has evolved in the course of a
year I remember I think I think it was
March last year when pub she came onto
the scene
so we've had a full cycle of you know
battle royale popularity being super
high now like someone like Bosque and
cliff B are jumping onto that train to
see you're a little bit of our resident
expert for better or worse do you think
you'll have to review this queue
probably I probably will so yeah I mean
I've reviewed pubsey I reviewed h1z1 and
just today my official fortnight battery
I'll review went live so you can check
that on the site after the show
obviously yeah after show or after yeah
after a lot of different things but yeah
the what kind of feeling you getting out
of this from the trailer I mean I I'm
I'm into the like ironically like gnarly
eighties aesthetic kind of kind of scene
you know I'm into that but I don't know
if that's enough for me to be like yeah
dropping everything gonna play this game
and I I don't know I
boskie has to do something that's that's
a lot different I'm yeah do something a
lot different for me to like break away
from other battle royale games yeah I
mean say what you want about lawbreakers
and its player account or ever but like
I've said this before is that
lawbreakers has a very sound foundation
like it plays well it feels well feels
great to actually play just I don't
think it was packaged in the most
interesting way so if they can translate
that that that's sort of very like tight
feel over to this game maybe that can be
how it carves out its niche because pub
G is very much like the streamline
tactical shooter fortnight is
streamlined well it depends i I came
from like early ARMA mods and early h1z1
so to me pub G is very much oh I'm
forgetting very defensive here on her
first day you don't talk [ __ ] about me
oh yeah also another thing that I'm
getting out of radical Heights is almost
the Saints Row vibe because when I was
thinking about games that could go
battle Royales like huh what about
saints row like in its open world and
it's all its crazies a meanness yeah
just totally like PvP enabled zones
everywhere yeah a lot of colors yeah and
all this fun stuff that's a good
comparison that's what I'm getting from
that we actually have more details that
we can run through
boskie plans to introduce new weapons
gadgets customization vehicles game show
events game modes and eventually a daily
weekly challenge system so this will be
a game as a service yes
interestingly lawbreakers publisher
Nexon said in an earnings report from
early January that quote the timing of
lawbreakers launched turned out to be
unfortunate specifically the blockbuster
PC online online game player unknowns
battlegrounds came out right about the
same time making the market environment
very tough for first-person shooters in
general and for lawbreakers well well
who knows how much truth there is to
that but you know there's only so many
people out there who are gonna play a
video games so I guess that they're
trying to say that pub she ate their
lunch I don't know yeah I'm not buying
it I don't know about that it's a lot of
you didn't buy but but the story of the
day is what are you saying I was gonna
do a cool transition that was you know
people did buy oh yes okay we could
finish your shot
no I actually forgot my thought and I do
not want to interrupt that transition
because that is a very good transition
anyway you know what game people did by
Michael yes
far cry 5s latest update improves co-op
support and fixes multiple gameplay bugs
cool that's that's nice and to be
expected yeah and that game is doing
quite well if you were watching before
Michael and I went live we did have a
far cry five potato mode that's a new
series here at GameSpot where Joey
breaks games I really like I really like
that show it's a good show
so you've got a little taste of it in
the pre-roll boaties
but yeah we all about pre-rolls here so
this isn't those kind of bugs Joey broke
it on purpose this is normal stuff so
far cry 5s title update for released on
PC last week and is now out for ps4 and
Xbox one so across the board yeah so
gameplay so we can just watch cool for
Christ I hope some gameplay and we're
gonna we're gonna run through some of
the highlights of this patch the patch
fixes various bugs and low occurrence
crashes I like that low occurrence
precious it's just low and save
corruptions in addition to oh snap
and online improvements so they are
improving the coop connectivity they
fixed low occurrence coop specific
walkthrough brakes fixed voice
communication issue where players could
be permanently muted which actually
sounds like it could just be a feature
and Herc was blowing up the client
player when in a helicopter they fixed
that okay and if you're familiar with
some of the other features that we've
been doing here at GameSpot we've done
quite a bit Jake in particular has done
quite a bit on far cry arcade so they
made some changes to that as well yeah
improved map download efficiency they
have fixed the various arcade gameplay
issues fixed an issue where the map
textures would be really low yeah and
not in the potato mode sense yeah again
accident they've also improved the PvP
matchmaking for arcade mode and finally
they fixed lobby loadout selection and
map selection problems yes and then
there's one PC patch only yeah which
fixes the fix issue where we that were
causing causing incorrect spawn if the
game was minimized during loading which
you do sometimes I know you tap out and
do something else while the game loads
but uh that was causing problems but now
wouldn't yeah I know there's also talk
of the constant nighttime Oh
but that not addressed in this this
update from what we have gathered here
but yeah I think there is I know people
were posting about fixes for that and I
know poor Rob Handler he encountered
that bug oh yeah he did
so yeah always big on bug rollouts
speaking of arcade though we do have
best arcade maps of the week but there's
one called the legend of zeldo that's
probably worth checking out and then
like we said potato mode did Far Cry 5
that's just a show where Joey just just
destroys it's adorable games and it's a
lot of fun yeah Joey Joey's one of our
best boys here at GameSpot and yeah so
far cry 5 has sold extremely well I mean
it's doing really well for us as well
well well well well well so yes that
game is being worked on if you're having
issues with it yeah and speaking of
content
dates Ghost Recon wildlands nicely done
Ghost Recon wildlands first special
operations will feature a free Splinter
Cell mission so you sell the news last
week there was like a Sam Fisher teaser
trailer and we got some follow-up on
that
so the Splinter Cell Special Operations
mission will be available for free
starting tomorrow which is April 10th
mm-hm
I don't know why it's not just spec ops
Special Operations spec ops is a
separate thing yeah I don't know I like
to abbreviate you got a abbreviate
Special Operations here though yeah it
doesn't sound like you'll actually play
a Sam Fisher yeah if you watch the
trailer it seems like you are in support
of him because if you're playing a Sam
Fisher that would be essentially a
splinter cell game oh yeah yeah and also
it's worth noting for Splinter Cell fans
that Michael Ironside is doing this way
yes which I know it was a big deal that
is a big deal real quick yeah I know
after conviction they went with a
different voice actor like his name is
Erik Johnson I don't want to get
someone's name wrong we have four
blacklist in 2013 they went with the
different voice actor who sounded 20
years younger thirty years younger
whatever but yeah in this particular
trailer which you can't hear right now
because it listened to us is that
Michael Ironside with this deep gravelly
voice yes he is voicing Sam Fisher in
the Ghost Recon wildlands special
operation yeah so the trailer for that
shows Sam Fisher infiltrating a Santa
Blanca cartel outpost before saying he
has some help from the ghosts and this
description of the trailer reads help
Sam Fisher complete his mission in a
special Splinter Cell operation and then
I think our buddy Matt Padgett who put
together our notes thinking Matt Padgett
put a frowny face oh yeah I don't know
why I don't know a whole lot about
Splinter Cell yeah because all someone
ourselves one of my favorites game
series of all time so maybe we were
hoping maybe he was hoping I wasn't
expecting to play a Sam Fisher yeah but
we were also talking about like hey what
soubise off gonna be showing for the
next
besides this Ghost Recon wildlands
content update which is a big deal which
is very cool to see yeah what else are
they gonna roll out soon and we're
thinking like oh boy isn't it time for a
new Splinter Cell and the answer is
hells yeah
but yes for now for now you can you can
have a little taste of Splinter Cell in
Ghost Recon wildlands so this mission is
available indefinitely but the rewards
are only available until May 16th so if
you want to get on those rewards got
plate now and it includes Sam's goggles
if that's something you like doing a
demonstration for you you did great
thank you
I very much like Splinter Cell Ghost
Recon wildlands we have talked in the
past some people are pretty into it some
people are kind of lukewarm on it I
think that it has a proved improved over
time
Ubisoft is demonstrating with games like
the division and Rosa say Ghost Recon
siege
Rainbow six age and now with wildlands
they are proving that they are
supporting their games and Ghost Recon
wildlands sold extremely well yeah so
there are a lot of people out there
playing it whether you like it or not is
up to you as it should be it's all up to
you
let's let's roll through we got oh
there's some other things there's some
other details about that's really fast
special operation one lands tomorrow
like we said there's also a year to pass
which includes new weapons the caramba
Karambit knife new night-vision goggles
Splinter Cell costume and Sam Fisher's
goggles like yes which you can also earn
or I'm not sure if like you get it with
the YouTube pass and you can also if you
don't even see pass you just play the
Splinter Cell mission and then get it
that way but uh no no your wildlands
players out there we'll find out yeah we
won't spoil that for you yeah why would
we oh and then ghost war pvp has a
sabotage mode and the Echelon class yeah
sabotage mode is from what I'm getting
out of it is a lot like a 1-1 life per
round kind of counter-strike yeah
diffuse mode yeah it's seems interesting
yes and then finally a last Ghost Recon
note in related news a free weekend will
be available in from April 12th to 15th
this week this weekend on ps4 Xbox one
PC and for Xbox one you have to have an
gold subscription
that's your opportunity to check it out
ye-yeah I'm totally gonna sneeze I'll
let you introduce this next one okay
cool boy you all were paying attention
yesterday a new Star Wars Han Solo movie
trailer dropped so we got another look
at Solo Star Wars story but more
importantly we got a good look at Lando
yeah well yeah let's drop it to that
real quick yeah gotta sneeze no it went
away okay well good yeah so we got the
trailer obviously we're gonna be talking
over it so if you haven't seen it you
want to watch we understand if you want
to pause and watch it and then come back
but we'll be playing it in the
background if you're watching and not
just listening so it opens on Hans home
planet and shows a Star Destroyer under
construction yes that is correct
and yeah the some of the some of the
villains are also showing off early on
and finesse
she's a she's a leader of the cloud
riders pirate gang so you're gonna see
Han getting into squabbles with her and
her cronies and also they revealed also
showed a Dryden Voss who is also going
to be I suppose another villain in this
movie yeah you see emilia clarke as kira
kira shown reuniting with han yeah she's
one of his uh I guess in the Han Solo
lore she is one of his oldest companions
yes and then of course oh yes Samba
lover
most importantly oh wait do we already
went over the Donald Glover because he's
coming up
Donald Glover looking real nice as Lando
Calrissian yeah he's I think like at
least from this I really got that that
swag from that Lando is all about Lana's
kind of a seedy guy he's he's not the
he's not someone you really want to deal
with it's kind of kind of a jerk but I
think Donald Glover is really channeling
I love him so much
look at oh he's so talented I love that
doing oh boy
and then you see what Woody Harrelson as
Tobias Beckett which is young Hans
mentor yeah and then there also there's
a there was a previous shot from past
teasers that showed
on with the review there his first
exposure to the Millennium Falcon and
then but in here we also see Chewie with
him yep so Chewie is forever hopeful no
spoilers but I don't think he's gonna
die in this one I have a feeling that
choo he's not gonna die just an inkling
it's just a premonition that I got um
there's obviously shady business going
on yeah you know Hans a smuggler so
there's you know it's gonna be like
crime and stuff which I'm excited for I
don't know what do you think what do you
think of the trailer I think it's cool
I think I just wanted to see more of it
if it was gonna see if it was gonna do
anything for me because yeah you know
rogue one was was dope I mean I love
drug one I know a lot of people didn't
but I really love drug one yeah Brooklyn
was was pretty dope I actually like the
new Star Wars trilogies of what we've
seen so far so force awakens I liked
yeah and I liked to varying degrees but
you know getting more and more Star Wars
I think that was to be expected when
Disney rolled through and swooped that
up and but from this I think that some
people are down on it but I think I'm
gonna give a chance
absolutely I'm gonna see it yeah and
when can we can we see it may 25th
that's real soon that's next month oh my
god it is now geez I just we just got
done watching last Jedi I already got
another Star Wars
another Star Wars story han Solo story
to be exact
yeah there's a lot going on in that
trailer I know it's only like two
minutes but it was I just watched it
this morning and I was like wow we both
watched it this morning and I mean
mainly I was like where's Don Glover
where it's not glower I've got to see
him and you did get to see him and he
talks and everything um of course we did
say we're going to cover six stories and
30 minutes or less we did that that was
exploited 26 minutes yes which means
there's room for us to uh kind of talk
about what's going on with our lives
okay here's what you got to know anime
aired this weekend new anime persona 5
my hero academia we got steins gate
coming up this week yeah you got check
it out check out the new anime we're
gonna have these anime segments anime
Mondays deal with it every day is an
anime day it is you're with us I'm sure
you watch persona already
did don't we'll talk about that later
nothing really despoil since this game
has been out for right there we don't
have time I know if we get into it we'll
go another half an hour yeah so this was
our first episode of GameSpot daily we
are really interested to hear what you
guys thought of the show if you liked it
but we should keep doing what we could
change what we do better please let us
know in the comments
we're on YouTube and twitch and keep
calm we can also you can tweet at us and
tell us what you thought of the show but
don't be mean because if you're mean
then we won't listen to you guess you
asked block yeah we also have to think
today Matt Padgett did the whole rundown
by himself he got all the stories
together and worked really hard and I
mean you did some notes for solo but
Matt Paget's great and we loved him and
then obviously I want to thank Emily
Conte puts her set together produces us
and Eric take came in and helped us oh
nice I want to thank Eric tattoos he's
shown me showing me the ropes yeah it's
not just us we're not the only people on
the show we're just the ones who talk at
you yeah and for all you who are
watching live or going to watch as a
later archived stream or video we want
to thank y'all yeah thank you for
joining us and we hope you liked the
show and that you'll join us tomorrow
cuz we're here every day every weekday
until we die if you're watching live we
do have a live stream at GameSpot just
after this 11:30 they're doing
extinction so you want to see that game
in action yeah I think it'll be a good
time I know Eric day and Ben Janka are
going to be heading that in a few
minutes so if you want to see what that
is all about the latest game from iron
galaxy if you're familiar with iron
galaxy and you'll know what they all
about but yes their new game extinction
will be live stream on GameSpot and a
minute in yeah so just don't go anywhere
maybe refresh the page and write not
sure how that works not super sure how
it works but refreshing the page is
always a good bet I think yeah we like
we said like the name implies do our
batteries is low which means we got to
go
yes--that's are telling us again get the
hell out of here so yes we're doing this
every day so please roll through when
you can chill with us we're just gonna
run through the news stay informs and
like I said you can chill with us so
that is our show yes and thank you again
for joining us we'll see you tomorrow
peace obey whoa that's not it
yeah no that's not it that's it yeah
[Laughter]